foreign
for facts all your friends let's do it
[Music]
the official song of NASCAR
is it no all right we're gonna give you
today I'm gonna give you four steps what
to do when the whole world has lost its
mind
and you find yourself just barely
hanging on
um we had another segment to discuss
today and I got up super early this
morning just spinning spinning spinning
spinning sat down and said I didn't put
all this on paper here
um there's so much uh and I'm just
thinking about my neighborhood so much
here in Nashville
um
everybody's still healing everybody
still yelling the politicians in the
city have just I don't I don't have the
words for it it's lost their minds just
lost their mind everybody's just bananas
um politics across the country I don't
care who you are
if you stop for a second and turn the
radio off
turn the TV off and you just roll your
window down and you're driving down the
road
you're being honest
both parties are insane insane
Madness
I was with some folks who are close
friends of mine who are different
politically this weekend on both sides
of the aisle
the most common refrain refrain was
I don't know who my party is anymore
they're insane
you're just regular old neighbors
regular good folks
I see tons of cowardice
and frightened and fear my neighbors and
my friends and across the country I'm
gonna be real honest with you this is
just me being vulnerable
seems cowardice when I look in the
mirror
I've seen fear when I look in the mirror
just I got two little kids man I brought
them into this mess
and I'm not just talking about Nashville
I'm talking about politics across the
country I'm talking about
um all the chaos then you step back and
you hear about like China's moves to
replace the dollar and shifting Global
priorities you can Ukraine Wars on and
on and on and then at home we've got
kids and grades and inflation it's too
expensive to move but it's I don't have
enough money in my in my current job all
of it
and if we're honest we're trying to do
two things one of two things I mean
we're either going to double down on
what we know and just try to do whatever
we were already doing faster or with
more Force more aggressively right or
more recklessly
which by the way that's Insanity it's a
Madness to keep doing the same thing
just faster and harder when you get
stuck whenever you find yourself in your
in your tires are in mud
just jamming on the gas just digs a huge
hole that you for sure are going to get
out of now
and that's what we're doing their lives
we're just getting angrier and more
frustrated and going and going and going
and going and yelling and frazzled or
just checking out we're done I'm out I'm
gonna have one more drink and one more
drink
I'm gonna watch one more Netflix episode
I'm gonna get super excited about the
next series I'm gonna spend all my time
talking about the next series the next
series because I've outsourced my lives
I'm done living them so I'm just gonna
let Ted lasso and let him live life for
me
I'm just gonna let office reruns that
I've already watched 700 times I'm gonna
let them have friendships in Romance and
joy and laughter and work hijinks
because I'm I'm done with my life I've
just cashed out
foreign
think of it like being in an aquarium
you're in an aquarium and there's water
pouring in and there's water the water
level is rising okay we have voices on
the right telling us we need to suck it
up and just learn how to swim we have
voices on the left just wanting to just
to focus on the stories about who's
dumping the water and we have voices
telling us
um from above that we need to build a
better and New Foundation at the bottom
of this aquarium and we have voices
below us telling us this is the way it's
always been and we're trapped and it's
all coming down and I want us just to
look around these narratives aren't
working even if there's truth in each
one of them it's not helping people
it's not
and I want to propose something new
let's just get out of the aquarium
let's just get out
just be done with it and not worry about
swimming or build what let's just get
out
because what you need right now is not
another new diet another scam not
another scroll in the news media by the
way the news stations do not care about
you they want your clicks and they want
your attention they want you to keep
spending your money they don't care
about you
politicians don't care about you they
want to keep their jobs and their power
to keep on spending your money that is
it
that's it
so what do we do
I'm going to give you four steps on what
do you do when you feel out of control
some of these are short-term like you
can do them right now some of these are
going to be long term it might take you
one two several years
okay but there's clear research that
when somebody finally gets the courage
to call a counselor
they actually start feeling better
when somebody gets an actual plan in
front of them and they say this plan
works and there's a line of people
who've done that plan and say hey this
this one works
that you actually stand taller you feel
better
be on a path having a direction is key
even if you're not all the way there
even if you're just starting okay and by
the way these things aren't great and
they are not fun
in fact initially they are not awesome
they're going to feel terrible some of
these are going to feel terrible you're
going to feel guilty you're going to say
things like I can't or I don't know how
here's what's beautiful about them I'm
not uh giving you some hack I'm not
running up a gimmick
I'm just telling you the truth like I
always do on the show
it's telling you the truth
and by the way this is a conversation I
had with myself at four or five this
morning
because I got up just spinning just
spinning this morning
when things are hopelessly con out of
control it feels Bleak or it feels dark
we are going to solve for Freedom here's
what that means that is not
um American flag underoosing Like an
Eagle going across this that's not what
I'm talking about
we are trapped chained to things we are
stuck in the aquarium so we're going to
look at the four ways we are chained to
the aquarium and we're going to cut the
chains
okay
number one
if you owe somebody money you can't just
move you can't get out of your abusive
job you can't get out of your parents
basement you can't look at your husband
and say you stop hitting or cheating on
me or I'm gone can't do that
because Ford Motor Company is telling
you what you're doing tomorrow your
mortgage company is telling you what
you're going to do tomorrow
Visa is telling you what you're going to
do tomorrow you are chained inside of
that aquarium you can't move
and yes I'm biased I work at Ramsey
Solutions we do we help people get out
of debt
doesn't matter doesn't mean it's not
true
and I take a more psychological angle
your body will not let you rest if
somebody else can just snatch your house
from you or just snatch your
transportation from you or just snatch
your food from you it won't let you
so stop pretending like you got a great
deal on a thing that you don't have to
pay for for 12 months whatever it's just
a couch
don't oh pay every debt off that you owe
pay them all off
this is a massive chain around your neck
pay it off pay it off all of them get
insane about it get radical about it
your life depends on it and by the way
while we're here stop waiting for the
government to pay off your debts for you
quit it pay them off you signed your
name I had to pay off six figures of
them
did I know what I was signing no but I
did I put my name on it as an 18 year
old and a 19 year old and a 20 year old
and a 25 year old I did it I did it
so I'm going to pay them off I'm going
to stop waiting on the government deal
it like an adult does it suck yes is it
the worst yes do it
my wife and I had to sell our nice house
and move into a tiny little apartment in
a dorm with a kid pay him off whatever
it takes whatever it takes pay him off
number two time we use our calendars as
a as a proxy for self-worth Monday night
is sports practice Tuesday is piano or
guitar Wednesday night of soccer
Thursday night is youth group or dance
Friday nights hang out with friends
Saturday night Saturdays are all day
sporting events and then hanging out
with friends Sunday is church or more
games or both plus schooling plus
commuting plus all the yoga and the
appointments at one point five hour
workout programs or Netflix shows or
baseball games stop stop you become a
slave to your calendar quit
quit
I was talking to somebody recently not
on air they needed to go to inpatient
treatment
for some significant trauma it's a
really incredible Brave person I was
talking with
their first response was but there's so
many things I've got to do who's going
to get them done
calendar
get with your account with your spouse
and begin canceling things
just cancel them just stop
create a day with nothing no plans no
electronics create a day or two for
hosting just hanging out with friends
and family tell them to bring their
whatever crap they have in the fridge
just bring it over
half of two liter of what I bring it
over I don't care old wine bring it over
try one sport and one lesson and that's
it that's it your kids are gonna be fine
if you drive six hours on a Saturday for
a nine-year-old soccer game
stop just stop
just stop
ask yourself is is your job worth dying
for
because for Bunches of you it's killing
you
and this one's hard for me because I am
a to the death workaholic
I am
I work to prove my self-worth and so
this one's hard for me
you are not your busy calendar a full
calendar does not mean a full life it
means you're choosing to distract
yourself from living a full life you're
running and running away number three
clutter junk
stuff everywhere okay so real quick in
18 seconds
our bodies are designed to live in a
world of scarcity
it's designed to eat with whatever you
can get your hands on
it's designed to if you've got water
we're going to drink Tumwater logged you
find a mate we are going to make make me
it's designed for scarcity and then boom
overnight we have
hacked the supply chains for food and
mates and everything they're everywhere
everything's everywhere
and then we also my granddad
um came out of the Great Depression
and he straightened up nails
because he had to my grandmother saved
string that came off of like clothes
because they had to they didn't couldn't
just go to the store and buy some
because there was no store and there was
no things and there was no money to buy
it if there had been a store so we've
got these bodies who are designed for
scarcity that are designed for scarcity
and then we have a picture one or two
generations away of people who saved
nails
and we have hit the pendulum so far that
we try to insulate ourselves from the
next big whatever with stuff more
clothes more shoes more bicycles more
weight equipment more workout programs
more digital clutter more passwords more
logins more whatever
our culture has no breaks on it when it
comes to this one magic word enough we
don't know how to do it
just start getting rid of stuff
go room by room make it a five month
transformation make it a 30-day
transformation my friends Joshua Fields
Milburn and rhinocademus and TK Coleman
they the minimalist they have a
challenge I think it's a third day
challenge where just on day one give
away one thing on day two give away two
things day three give away three things
by the time you get to the end of the
month 30 days or 31 days you're giving
away 30 things and over the course of
that month it's add up to a ton of stuff
you've given away
close
collections one day these Beanie Babies
are gonna come back they're not they're
not coming back stop
your life
pair down your life paired on your life
appeared on your life
closets or garages our attics our
storage spaces
our bank accounts our laptops it's
insanity
get rid of the Clutter
fourth
this is a whole book read Nidra to
Webb's book called Boundaries find
boundaries find peace
my friend Henry clouds got book out
boundaries it's Masterpiece it's awesome
who is telling you what you have to do
with your life your parents your in-laws
your abusive spouse your old professor
ask yourself this terrifying question
what do I want with my life
and then ask yourself this other scary
question what do I want this month and
then ask yourself an even more
terrifying question and if you're
married do it with your spouse tomorrow
what do I want for today
and what is happening today that's going
to get me to this life that I want
this is solving for freedom
with your money with your time with your
clutter your boundaries
solve for it
it's all for freedom
and here's a bonus one phone a friend
get a friend to work through this with
you but you're married whether you're 18
whether you're 72 call a friend
the world's gonna go bananas and we've
lived in a pocket of history when things
have been relatively stable especially
for large swaths of the West those days
may be over
not in a bad dramatic way just we've had
some pretty stable times
some stable decades
I expect Ascension I expect chaos I
expect people to be self-serving I can't
do anything about them but I can't
control me I'm gonna look at every angle
of my life and solve for Freedom
especially in those four areas
let me get out of the aquarium as
quickly as possible and if this sin
sense of panicky and you good good
leave work early and sit down with your
husband or your wife and say we're gonna
do this now
and on the way you're going to find grit
and strength and resilience that you did
not know you had
you're going to find out that you can do
anything
and then
you will be truly
free